well today is the last day of school  before winter break for ccsd  you know it's been a difficult school  year for everyone students  teachers and parents superintendent dr  jesus jarrah  acknowledged everyone's sacrifice in his  annual holiday message  none of us could have prepared for what  we faced in 2020  but you all worked so hard so tirelessly  to do the best that we could for our  children  our staff and our community i know  it has not been easy and i am so  grateful  for each and every single one of you  he said he knows there will be  challenges in the new year but he is  confident better times are ahead we put  that entire video for  you on our website if you'd like to see  it eight news now dot com